mai zusammen heute gehts blätterteig
teilchen mit pudding auf die schnelle
art auf die einfache art und natürlich
wie immer auf die leckere art
[Musik]
hier findet die ganz genauen
mengenangaben wie immer unten in der
video beschreibung ich lege direkt los
ich bin uns heute tiefgekühlten
blätterteig den gibt es in der
quadratestadt und in der rechteckigen
form habe ich jetzt die zehn minuten
lang auftauen lassen damit ein bisschen
weicher wird und jetzt nehme ich mir
meine pizza rad und schneidet das
jeweils in der hälfte einmal durch
[Musik]
die bilddatei gibt dann auf das mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech tun und
mit wasser bepinseln das machen wir
deshalb damit unser zucker jetzt daran
haften bleibt ich habe auch wirklich nur
ein bisschen zucker angenommen also
wirklich nur so ungefähr einen halben
teelöffel pro quadrat und jetzt wandern
die blätterteig in den backofen ich
nehme dieses mal um luft 190 grad umluft
ist deshalb gut weil desertec soll er
ebenso ein bisschen austrocknen und
knusprig werden und ich sage euch dann
im anschluss wie lange sie bei mir
gebraucht haben
[Musik]
schon nach zwölf minuten sind sie
perfekt durch gebacken und jetzt einfach
stehen lassen und auskühlen lassen und
ich kümmere mich so lange und wie fülle
ich mache jetzt im neckartäle pudding
habe ich hier schon alles vorbereitet
und zwar benötigen wir auch nur vier
zutaten milch speisestärke zucker
vanille extrakt das war's ich fahre
jetzt auch alles im topf auf den herd
noch nicht einschalten erst klümpchen
frei verrührt und dann schalte ich den
herd ein und lasst es schön eindecken
[Musik]
den eingelegten vanillepudding dann kurz
umfüllen direkt an der oberfläche
abdecken und vollständig auskühlen
lassen bei mir ist es vollständig
ausgekühlt und das coole ist dass man
hier auch kein ein brauch also ihr habt
normalerweise im pudding an geld dann
wisst ihr nicht was er mit dem eiweiss
machen soll das fällt komplett weg
es gibt das jetzt in meine maschine das
geht auch mit dem schneebesen dann müsst
ihr nur richtig kraft an wänden und in
der maschine braucht es jetzt nur so
eine halbe minute
dass ich das einmal fluffig schlage und
dann finde ich es um einen spritzbeutel
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt übrigens befüllt tele
vorne dran ich finde das am einfachsten
weil das hat dieses feine spitze ihr
müsst dann quasi nur durch die blätter
teilchen stechen und dann den pudding
einfüllen und es macht auch richtig
sparen wenn wir sind ihr lieblings
partie
[Musik]
als nächstes werden wir zeit später
kuvertüre temperieren ihr könntet auch
wenn ihr kein zartbitter fans könnte
auch voll mich nehmen es auch gar kein
thema ich habe jetzt hier einen topf mit
heißem wasser einmal aufkochen lassen
dann abgeschaltet habe ich jetzt hier
vorliegen und obendrüber eine feuerfeste
schüssel witte nimmt nur feuerfeste
schüssel damals als ich noch unerfahren
war habe ich mal eine schüssel darüber
gegeben die nicht vorher fest war und
dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen was
passiert ist auf jeden fall werde ich
jetzt zwei drittel der kuvertüre hier
drin schmelzen über dem wasserbad und
nehmen es dann runter und gäbe ein
drittel mit dazu also ihr spielt quasi
die gesamtmenge einmal auf damit ihr
später keinen grauschleier haben
[Musik]
also bei der deko könnt ihr frei
entscheiden ich habe mich da gerade mit
der weißen schokolade noch so ein
bisschen ausprobiert ansonsten könnte
das doch klassisch lassen ihr könnt
jetzt auch mit puderzucker bestäuben
aber ich finde dass die schokolade das
ganze nochmal richtig abrundet und wird
zwei wir können uns das jetzt noch
kaffee dazu schön auf dem balkon sitzen
und dann einfach nur gönnen
klar wollte siehst du nein nein
also ich finde euch ganz viel freude ihm
nachmachen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten rezept beim nächsten blog oder
bei der zweiten folge kitchen heck sie
komme nicht bei den video mal wieder
also bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]